All right. Let's here it.
>> Okay. So here's the process that I went through.
I'm just going to talk this out. I haven't actually worked it
out in my head yet. So what's the probability that there
isn't a storm? Well the way you have this drawn it
actually makes it pretty easy to see. I can just look
at the cases where storm is false, and it turns out
there's two of them. And I can just add those probabilities
over there, and I get .05 plus .30, and that gives
me .35.
>> That's great. Yes, so that's exactly what
you did. So you went through, and now all
that matters in the universe are the cases where
they're not a storm and that ended up being
these two numbers. And you said, well Those are
two different cases that can happen. We'll just add
their probabilities because they're not overlapping and you've got
.35. Great. All right what about the second question?
>> Okay, so that's probability that there's
lightning in a world where there's a storm
so I'm going to do a very similar trick. I'm going
to look at the cases where storm happens to be true.
And conveniently they're the first two rows and I have
two cases, so we know the probability of there being a
storm is 0.65 which is good, because 0.65 and 0.35
add up to one. But that's not the probability of there
being lightening, given there is a storm. So, of those two
cases, there's only one where lightening is happening, windstorm is happening,
and that's 0.25. But 0.25 isn't enough because it's only 0.25 out of 0.65.
>> Hm.
>> So the correct answer would be 0.25
divided by 0.65. Which is, some number. 5 13th's?
>> Yeah. It's 5 13th's. And, though I'd
rather that people fill it in as a fraction.
>> As a, wait. That is a 5 13ths is a fraction.
>> Good point. As a point something something. A decimel.
>> So, 5 13ths is obviously 0.4615. And there you go. Is that right?
>> Yes. That was perfect. Yeah so its usually when there's a
storm, its not lightningy. It's less than half the time. That makes sense.
>> It does because otherwise lightning would be happening all the time.
>> Well when its storming. It could
be that its very likely when its storming.
>> It is likely when it's storming, but it wouldn't be happening
every time its storming because otherwise it would be lightning all the time
when its storming.
>> RIght.
>> And often there's breaks between lighting. In fact, most of the time
there's not lightning, at least outside my window. At 2pm. In the summer.